[موسيقى]
كان rasmus hoigard يخطو للتو في تقدمه
في اللعبة الاحترافية عندما
ضرب الوباء الجولة الأوروبية في مارس / آذار الماضي ،
ولكن مع مرور عام كمحترف وفوزه الأول
تحت حزامه
، لم يكن وقتًا سيئًا للشاب الدنماركي
خذ خطوة للوراء ،
فهل استمتعت حقًا ببعض
الوقت الأكثر هدوءًا خلال الوباء هل
كانت فرصة للتوقف عن العمل
تمامًا ، لقد كان لدي دائمًا شغف
بألعاب الفيديو ، لذلك
كان لدي بعض الوقت لأتحسن في ذلك
وقضاء بعض الوقت  الوقت هناك كان
مريحًا للغاية لأنك فجأة لم
تفكر في
أي لعبة غولف أو أي شيء متعلق
بالجولف ، وأعتقد أن ذلك كان مفيدًا جدًا بالنسبة لي بمجرد بدء الجولة مرة أخرى ، لم يكن على hoigard الانتظار طويلاً لتحقيق
فوزه الاحترافي الثاني
هذه المرة في أيقونة الجولة الأوروبية
برج الجرس ،
هل يمكنك وصف مشاعرك
فيما يتعلق بهذه النهاية لبطولة المملكة المتحدة
للفوز في برج الجرس والحصول على المركز
الثاني في الجولة الأوروبية انتصارًا آخر
نعم كان مذهلاً  في الواقع ، كان هناك القليل
من التمدد الغريب أيضًا لأنني
أصبت في قدمي اليمنى في قدمي اليمنى
ولم أستطع التدرب لمدة تسعة أيام ، وكانت البطولة التالية
بالنسبة لي هي برج الجرس
فجأة ولم أتطرق إلى  النادي قبل
الجمعة السبت قبل ذلك الأسبوع ،
مرة أخرى كان ذلك ثمانية تسعة أيام
بدون لعبة
غولف وهذا هو المكان الذي اختفت فيه اللمسات
مرة أخرى
أو هذا ما اعتقدته ومن الواضح أنني
عدت إلى الجرس
وألعب بعض الجولف الجيد ولكن هذا غريب
أحيانًا عندما أفكر  لا تتوقع
الكثير من
نفسك عندما تلعب بعضًا
من أفضل لعبة غولف لديك
وأعتقد أن هذا ما حدث لي بالنسبة
لهويجارد
أن الروح التنافسية تعود
إلى الولادة مع وجود منافس طبيعي
بجانبه طوال فترة لعبه.  الحياة في
شكل شقيقه التوأم وزميله
المحترف نيكولاي ،
إنه شيء رأيناه منذ أن
بدأنا لعب الجولف في سن مبكرة ، كان
المرء سيحظى بعام جيد جدًا ثم
العام التالي
سيكون e  ven أفضل في العام التالي ، ثم
كان دائمًا صعودًا
وهبوطًا ورأى نيكولاي في 18 عامًا كان
عامًا لا يصدق حيث
فاز أحد الهواة بكل شيء
لعبه إلى حد كبير ، لذا كان
أداءنا الصغير أو أيًا كان ما تسميه
هذا
رائعًا جدًا بطريقة ما  يمكننا
دائمًا دفع بعضنا البعض وقد فعلنا
ذلك
لأنه حتى في المدرسة ولعب
كرة اليد أو كرة القدم ، كان دائمًا مثل
من يمكن أن يكون
الأفضل وقد ساعدنا
بالتأكيد كثيرًا
في لعبة الجولف أيضًا في عام 2021
كما تعلم  هناك الكثير قادمًا ، هناك
بعض
الأحداث الكبيرة ، ربما تكون قد
لعبت كأس الناشئين مع
شقيقك نيكولاي
هو أن هذا هدف مهم بالنسبة لك أو
هل لديك أهداف أخرى الآن للعام
المقبل ،
فإن كأس رايدر هو بالتأكيد هدف
تريده  تريد الانضمام إلى فريق
كلاعب أوروبي أشعر أن هذا بعيد جدًا
في الوقت الحالي ، لذا فهو ليس شيئًا
أهتم به ، لقد تلقيت بعض الدروس في
هذا العام حيث بدأت في البحث
كثيرًا  ذ  تصنيفات مختلفة ولم
يكن ذلك مفيدًا بالنسبة لي ، فهو ليس
المكان الذي يجب أن يكون التركيز
عليه ولعب الجولف جيدًا ، لذا
يجب أن يكون هذا هو الشيء
للعام المقبل